one of the greatest opportunities we
have particularly from the perspective
of the university is how can we improve
human health globally today 30,000
children under the age of 5 die every
day
it's an enormous number and it's
avoidable but when we need to avoid that
we really have to learn how to create
the evidence and disseminate the
evidence from a university to the field
where these stuffs are happening where
the health is really not as strong as it
could be one of the ways in which Yale
is doing this is we have something
called the Global Health Leadership
Institute and its major mission is to
develop strong relationships between
Yale faculty who are producing new
evidence and the actual field the
delegations that come from the country
policymakers practitioners communities
from the country where we can really
make a link between the Yale faculty who
are producing what needs these countries
need to take up and the country
leadership themselves an example that's
a good one to think about is the work
that Yale is doing in Ghana through the
global health Leadership Institute both
with the economic growth center and the
School of Public Health faculty here
engaged with faculty at the University
of Ghana have been able to document that
nearly seven percent of the GDP in Ghana
has been foregone in large part due to
the mental health problems and the
psychological distress which translates
into people not being able to work
questions asked to community members in
Ghana how many days have you been unable
to work due to your emotional distress
in the last month have helped us
document exactly how much of the GDP has
been for gone this is an incredibly
important problem for the first time the
President of Ghana was able to say I
could invest in mental health not just
because it's the right thing to do but
it makes economic sense
it will help development in Ghana and
that's something we can do in multiple
countries with getting faculty engaged
with the actual policymakers in these
countries